mr president
thank you
for showing
the world what it means
to stand up
thank you
for reminding us
about the dangers
of complacency
everyday acts of extraordinary heroism
by ukrainians inspire us all
defence forces and citizens making the
ultimate sacrifice
to delay
a column of tanks
senior citizens standing up to face down
russian troops with nothing but pride
and sunflowers as their weapon
brave women
forced to give birth in metro stations
next to their kalashnikovs
they showed the world
that our way of life
is worth
defending
it is worth
a cost
all those who remember
living under occupation will attest to
that
all those standing up
in belarus
all those
looking to us
in moldova
in georgia
it is
worth it for us
for the next generation
for all those in ukraine
and around the world who believe in
europe and in our way
and for all those
who want to be free
our european response was on display
over the last very painful days
this must be
our whatever it takes
moment
neighboring states have accepted
hundreds of thousands of fleeing
ukrainians
europeans sheltered ukrainians in their
homes
we have implemented a series of
unprecedented
massive sanctions
we have gone further and will provide
much needed weapons to ukraine
we have declared that russian aircraft
and oligarchs private jets are no longer
welcome in our open skies
we have moved for russia to be
disconnected from the swift system
we have banned
we have banned kremlin propaganda tools
european citizens organizations
businesses sports have taken a clear and
forceful stand underlining that they
will not deal with or welcome an
aggressor and europe
stands ready to go further
still
we recognize
europe's
ukraine's
european
perspective
and as our resolution clearly states we
welcome mr president
ukraine's application for candidate
status and we will work
towards that goal
because we will
because we will and we must
face the future together
mr president we stand with you in your
fight for survival
in this dark moment in our history
when you look to this european
parliament
you will always find an ally
a space to address europe and the world
and always
always a friend
this european parliament has a long
proud history of being a thorn in the
side of autocrats
and in this spirit i will seek a ban
on any representatives of the kremlin
from entering european parliament
presences
because aggressors
because aggressors
and warmongers have no place
in the house of democracy
dear president dear members let me
finish out by stealth setting out four
important principles
for our future first of all
europe can no longer remain reliant on
kremlin gas
we need to redouble our efforts
to diversify our energy systems towards
a europe that is no longer at the behest
of autocrats that will put our energy
security on stronger footing secondly
europe can no longer welcome kremlin
cash and pretend that there are no
strings attached
putin's oligarchs and those who bankroll
him should no longer be able to use
their purchasing power to hide behind a
veneer of respectability in our cities
in our communities or in our sports
clubs
their super yachts should find no harbor
in our europe and we can no longer
[Applause]
and we can no longer
sell passports to putin's friends
allowing them
to circumvent
our security
no more
thirdly
investment in our defence must match
our rhetoric
europe must move to have a real
security and defense union
we have shown
last week that it is possible and
desirable and more than anything
it is
necessary
and fourthly
we must fight the kremlin's
disinformation campaign
and i call on social media and tech
conglomerates to take their
responsibility seriously and to
understand that there is no being
neutral between the fire and the fire
brigade
president michelle president wander lyon
high representative borel
thank you for ensuring european unity
and commitment in facing this threat
i know that all of us
all the members of this house will take
the united message of europe back to our
constituencies
president zelensky
thank you
we are together now
we will be together in the future
because we are with ukraine thank you
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
he
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
m
foreign
[Music]
is
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
okay
so
so
thank you very much for your strength
message strong message uh president for
your bravery and for your
conviction uh i will now give the floor
to the speaker of the ukraine parliament
ruslan stefan chuck for his intervention
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
mr
[Applause]
[Music]
is
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
history
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
is a woman
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
thank you very much mr speaker thank you
for your words for your courage and for
your commitment
to peace and parliamentary democracy
i give the floor now to the president of
the european council shall michelle for
his statement
lemur
[Music]
[Music]
five days ago
vladimir putin launched
a brutal
massive invasion of ukraine
and unjustified and unprovoked war
based on the speakable lies
and he did it
only for one reason
because you
develop the resiliency you dear people
of ukraine
in maidan
you made the choice of freedom
democracy and rule of law
and their colleagues
it's not only ukraine
that's under attack
international law
rules-based international order
democracy human dignity are also under
attack
this is
geopolitical terrorism pure and simple
we must support ukraine and you are we
are supporting ukraine
we must protect peace we must protect
democracy and international law
and ladies and gentlemen
out in the atlantic alliance
is strong
united
perfectly coordinated and we are also
working closely with the members of the
g7 and with the united nations and more
and more countries are engaging in an
anti-war coalition along with people
from around the world
with one common message
one common message russia
stop the raw go home let's torch
we are putting maximum pressure on
russia and its leaders we are stepping
up to support ukraine and the ukrainian
people i salute with all of you
president zelinski and the brave people
of ukraine for their courage and
composure
and it's also our duty to rise to this
historic moment
ladies and gentlemen
we promised
together that we would react quickly
that the consequences for russia would
be massive and severe and our actions
have matched our words we have responded
with massive and unprecedented sanctions
we imposed sanctions on political and
military leaders on oligarchs on
vladimir putin on saturday liverov we
are also taking powerful measures to
severely restrict the use of the foreign
currency reserve of the russian central
bank we are excluding key russian banks
from the swift system
and
we are also
imposing severe sanctions on these
sectors of russia's economy
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
trump
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
thank you very much president uh
michelle i now give the floor to the
high representative of the union for
foreign affairs and security policy
joseph
borrel for his statement
dear members of the european parliament
i will try to
share with you my thoughts
on the meaning of the tragic events that
we are living
and the provisional lessons that we can
draw from them
especially for the
common security and defense policy
which i had the honor to try to develop
and remains
an intergovernmental policy
a policy which is
yet in the hands of the member states
but cannot be implemented efficiently
without the strong cooperation
of the commission competences
i think this is the
the moment in which
the geopolitical europe
is being born
lacked the nations of europe geopolitics
you
but it is really the return of tragedy
to which europe is being confronted
today
the return of tragedy
far from frightening us
should galvanize us
first
because it believes the idea that the
european project had lost its momentum
because the
horizon
of the war
has been faded
unfortunately not
this reminds us that the abil the
tragedy and the war
never
fade away
and it's about the relationship with war
with the useless force with the violence
who have been debating here we have been
debating for years
to find out can europe can counter it
and this is why in the recent years we
have talked more about defense issues
that in the past
and we have begun to set up joint
military programs
that's why the european parliament
itself has voted to set this european
defense fund and the member states has
created this european peace facility
that now we are mobilizing in order to
provide arms to ukraine
european council
the networks will adopt the strategic
compass
and with the invasion of ukraine by
russia
we must amplify our reflection
adjust our means and anticipate our
responses
because one of the lessons that we have
to learn from the invasion of ukraine
is that more than ever europe must to
think strategically about itself
its environment and the world
this is no longer a luxury
a necessity
europe must amplify this reflection on
security issues and european parliament
has had an important role to play in
this regard
we think
we need to think about the instrument
of coercion
retaliation
and counter-attack
in the face of reckless adversaries
because all we need to understand
is that to make peace we need to be too
but to make woe
is enough to be one
this is exactly what mr putin is telling
us
and that's why we have to increase our
deterring capacity
a lot
we need to increase our deterrence
capacity in order to prevent war
and it's
and it's clear
that our deterrent has not been strong
enough
to stop mr putting aggression
but since this aggregation has started
we have reacted in the last few days in
a way that mr putin didn't expect
and we are showing him
that we will never sacrifice our freedom
and the freedom of others on the altar
of our well-being and prosperity
being president of this parliament in
2007
i had the opportunity to tell to mr
putin i twice
on the aftermath of the killing of a
journalist anna perezkaia i told him we
are not going to change human rights by
your gas
and this is the moment to repeat
and to act on that
we will not share
we will not
we will not abandon the defense of our
human rights and freedom
because we are more or less dependent on
russia and we have to start working
quickly as the commission has proposed
in order to cancel this dependency
last saturday
after having hold another foreign first
council
and attending the debate of the european
union council
i was talking with you president
michelle
and you told me
are we doing everything we can
is there something more than we can do
is that enough
how are we so
so powerless
and you told me thing do act we have to
push member states in order to adopt
decision on shift and to take russia out
of the financial system
think about how can we earn
ukraine not country by country one after
all in an uncoordinated manner
and you encourage me to talk with member
states again in few hours we agreed on
using this european peace facility in
order to bring financial support and
coordinate member states on arming
ukrainian army and people
in less than 24 hours another taboo had
fallen
and the president of the commission
immediately
showing a strong leadership start
working in order to get an agreement
with our international partners in order
to make possible to switch off russia
from the financial system and you know
what now
half of the reserves of the central bank
of russia
are completely out of their control they
are frozen do you imagine
this is the coercion
capacity three days ago it was
impossible and now it's possible and
they start feeling the consequences in
terms of inflation and the fall of their
currency
yes we have capacities
we have mobilized these capacities
and we have to continue doing so
putting together the capacities with the
member states
and the european union i want to
remember you that the european peace
facility is not part of the budget that
you vote
is another budget is an interventional
fund
managed by the member states
because we claim that we european union
with a peaceful force and we cannot
provide arms to anyone else yes we can
yes we have done
on the next budget think about it
once you vote the next budget
use your budgetary capacity you have the
budgetary capacity of this institution
to put the waste means in order to face
the next crisis and the next russian
aggression
we are also working
with
domain international
in coalition
traditionally
no
[Music]
capacity
poderosa
much
thank you very much
thank you very much high representative
i now give the floor to the president of
the european commission ursula
underlying for a statement
madam president of the european
parliament mr president of the council
high representative
mr president of the ukraine dia
volodomir mr speaker of the ukrainian
parliament
my honorable members
war has returned to europe
almost 30 years after the balkan wars
and over half a century after soviet
troops marched into prague and budapest
civil defence sirens again went off
in the heart of a european capital
thousands of people fleeing from bombs
camped in underground stations holding
hands
crying silently trying to cheer each
other up
cars lined up towards ukrainian western
borders
and when many of them ran out of fuel
people picked up their children and
their backpacks and marched for tens of
kilometers towards our union
they sought refuge inside our borders
because their country wasn't safe any
longer
because inside ukraine a gruesome death
count has begun
men women children are dying once again
because a foreign leader president putin
decided that their country ukraine has
no right to exist and we will never ever
let that happen and never ever accept
that
honourable members this is a moment of
truth for europe and let me quote the
editorial of one ukrainian newspaper the
keith independent published just hours
before the invasion began and i quote
this is not just about ukraine it's a
clash of two worlds two polar set of
values
end of quote
they are so right this is a clash
between the rule of law and the rule of
the gun
between democracies
and autocracies
between a rules-based order and a world
of naked aggression
how we respond today to what russia is
doing
will determine the future of the
international system
the destiny of ukraine is at stake but
our own fate also lies in the balance
we must show the power that lies in our
democracies
we must show the power of people that
choose their independent path freely and
democratically this is our show of force
and today a union of almost half a
billion people has mobilized for ukraine
the people of europe are demonstrating
in front of russian embassies all across
our union
many of them have opened their homes to
ukrainian fleeing from putin's bombs
and let me thank specially poland
romania slovakia and hungary for
welcoming these women men and children
europe will be there for them not only
in the first days but also in the weeks
and months to come that must be our
promise altogether
and this is why we are proposing to
activate the temporary protection
mechanism to provide them with a secure
status and access to schools medical
care and work they deserve it we need to
do that now
and we know this is only the beginning
more ukrainians will need our protection
and solidarity we are
and we will be there for them
our union is showing a unity of purpose
that makes me
proud at the speed of light
the european union has adopted three
waves of heavy sanctions
against russia's financial system
its high-tech industries and its corrupt
elite
and this is the largest sanctions
package in our union's history
we do not take these measures lightly
but we feel we had to act
these sanctions will take a heavy toll
on the russian economy and on the
kremlin
we are disconnecting key russian banks
from the swift network
we also banned the transaction of
russia's central bank the single most
important financial institution in
russia and this paralyzes billions of
foreign reserves turning off the tap on
russia's and putin's war we have to end
this financing of this war
and second
we target important sectors of the
russian economy
we are making it impossible for russia
to upgrade its oil refineries to repair
and modernize its air fleet and to
access many important technologies it
needs to build a prosperous future we've
closed our skies to russian air club
aircraft including the private jets of
oligarchs and make no mistake
we will freeze their other assets as
well be it yachts or fancy cars or
luxury prosperities will freeze that all
together
and thirdly
in another unprecedented step
we're suspending the licenses of the
kremlin's propaganda machine
the state-owned russia today and sputnik
and all as their and all of their
subsidiaries
will no longer be able to spread their
lies on to justify putin's war and to
divide our union
and these unprecedented actions by the
european union and our partners
in response of an unprecedented
aggression by russia
each one of these steps has been closely
coordinated with our partners and allies
the united states
the united kingdom
canada and norway but also for example
japan south korea and australia
all of these days you see that more than
30 countries representing well over half
of the world's economy
have also announced sanctions and export
controls on russia
and if putin was seeking to divide the
european union to weaken nato and to
break the international community he has
achieved exactly the opposite we are
more united than ever and we will stand
up in this war that is for clear that we
will overcome and we will prevail we are
united and we stay united
[Applause]
honourable members
i am well aware that these sanctions
will come at a cost for our economy too
i know this
and i want to speak honestly to the
people of europe
we have endured two years of pandemic
and we all wished that we could focus on
our economic and social recovery
but i believe
the people of europe understand very
well
that we must stand up against this cruel
aggression
yes protecting our liberty comes at a
price
but this is a defining moment and this
is the cost we are willing to pay
because freedom is priceless honorable
members this is our principle freedom is
priceless
our investments today
will make us more independent tomorrow
and i'm thinking first and foremost
about our energy security
we simply cannot rely so much on a
supplier that explicitly threatens us
and this is why we reached out to other
global suppliers and they responded
norway is stepping up in january we had
the record supply of lng gas we're
building new lng terminals and working
on interconnectors
but in the long run
it is our switch to renewables and
hydrogen that will make us truly
independent
we have to accelerate the green
transition because every kilowatt hour
of electricity europe generates from
solar wind hydropower or biomass reduces
our dependency on russian gas and other
energy sources
this is a strategic investment
and my honorable members
this is a strategic investment because
on top less dependency on russian gas
and other
fossil fuel sources also means less
money for the kremlin's war chest this
is also a truth
we are resolute
europe can rise up to the challenge
the same is true on defense european
security and defense has evolved more in
the last six days than in the last two
decades
most member states have promised
deliveries of military equipment to
ukraine
germany announced that it will meet the
two percent goal of nato as soon as
possible
and our union for the first time ever
is using the european budget to purchase
and deliver military equipment to a
country that is under attack
500 million euros for the european peace
facility
to support ukraine's defense
as a first batch we will now also match
this
by at least 500 million euro from the eu
budget to deal with a humanitarian
consequences of this tragic war
both in the country and for the refugees
honorable members
this is a watershed moment for our union
we cannot take our security and the
protection of people for granted
we have to stand up for it we have to
invest in it we have to carry our fair
share of the responsibility
and this crisis is changing europe
but russia has also reached
a crossroad
the actions of the kremlin are severely
damaging the long-term interests
of russia and its people
more and more russians understand this
as well
they are marching for peace and freedom
and how does the kremlin respond to this
by arresting thousands of them but
ultimately
the longing for peace and freeze and
freedom cannot be silenced
there is another russia besides putin's
tanks and we extend our hand of
friendship to this other russia be
assured they have our support
[Applause]
honorable members
in these days independent ukraine
is facing a darkest hour
at the same time the ukrainian people
are holding up the torch of freedom for
all of us
they are showing immense courage
they are defending their lives
but they are also fighting for universal
values
and they are willing to die for them
president zielenski and the ukrainian
people are a true inspiration
and when we last spoke
he told me again about his people's
dream to join our union
today the european union and ukraine are
already closer than ever before
there's still a long path ahead
we have to end this war
and we should talk about the next steps
but i am sure
nobody in this hemi cycle can doubt
that the people that stand up so bravely
for our european values
belongs in our european family
and therefore honorable members
i say
long live europe
and long live a free and independent
ukraine
mess vomit slava ukrainian
[Applause]
thank you
[Applause]
thank you very much
thank you very much president van der
lyon we now move to the speakers on
behalf of the political group starting
with manfred weber for the epp group
[Applause]
is
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
via steen and
thank you
president weber i now give the floor on
behalf of the s d group to iracia garcia
perez
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
i now give the floor
on behalf of the renewed europe group to
stefan sessions
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you very much
i now give the floor on behalf of the
green group to philip lambert
dear ukrainian friends
we do not have enough words to praise
your courage and determination to defend
your freedom
your resistance is a wake-up call to all
democrats around the world
without the will to fight
democracy will perish
to your aggressor i say
your life for justifying war
cannot
and will not remain unchallenged no mr
putin ukraine is not ruled by nazis on
the contrary it's legitimately elected
president stems from a family who was
blooded in the holocaust
no mr putin there's no genocide going on
in the donbas
what is happening there is a war that
you yourself started eight years ago
which took already 14 000 clips and that
your invasion brings only to a new level
no mr putin
ukraine has never intended to get
nuclear weapons on the country
it relinquished voluntarily does it
inherit it in 1991 from the soviet union
in exchange
for its territorial integrity which you
have been trampling on ever since you
you annexed crimea in 2014. no mr putin
there was no perspective for ukraine to
join nato in the foreseeable future
and if there is such an aspiration in
ukraine as there was in so many nations
once subjugated by the soviet union your
aggression against ukraine explains why
no mr putin the nato member states has
no intention to deny the russian
people's rights to peace and security it
is your reckless actions that imperil
those legitimate aspirations
the reality mr putin is that the people
of ukraine chose for freedom
for democracy
for rule of law for peace
and that choice
made by a people so close to russia's by
history and geography was never a threat
to russia's security but to the very
existence of your authoritarian and
kleptocratic rule
this is the real reason for the invasion
at the cost of precious human lives and
livelihoods both ukrainian and russian
the reality mr putin is that your brutal
aggression against the ukrainian people
is doomed to fail
you want wanted to deny their very
existence as a people
your aggression in cementing the unity
against the invader
as citizens of the european union we
know that the war on ukraine
is more than just an aggression against
the foreign state
it is a direct challenge to the values
that lie at the foundation of our union
ever since it was started
the european project
was and remains a peace project
so that the rule of brute force be
replaced by the rule of law
so that democracy
dialogue
compromise and cooperation across
national borders provide the best basis
for shared
and sustainable prosperity
we europeans cannot stand by idle when a
partner country is invaded and when all
fundamental values are challenged in
such a brutal way
this is why
short of direct military intervention
which would be foolish we must
and we will provide the ukrainian people
with all the support we can in order to
face the aggression
this is why we must and we will provide
safe haven
without
any
discrimination to all those who are
fleeing the world to seek refuge on our
territory
this is why we must and we will mobilize
all political economic and financial
means at all disposal to exert maximal
pressure on putin's russia in order to
make him stop his aggression
and let me be clear to the people of
russia
we have no quarrel with you
you too have the right to live in
dignity and many of you are standing up
daily to defend it at great personal
risk
we know that resuming the diplomatic
dialogue with your country is the only
path to a sustainable
peace on our continent but this can only
happen if the aggression
stops
as far as europeans meeting the
challenge put to us by putin's war will
test our strength or determination and
above all or unity
it will not come cheap
therefore it will force us to make hard
choices
the first must be for cohesion within
and across member states
the global financial crisis the eurozone
crisis and the pandemic have deepened
social and economic injustice in our
union
it cannot be
that once again the brunt of the massive
efforts required to counter putin's war
will be carried by the weaker shoulders
should that be the case the legitimate
resentment would sub the very basis of
our social contract as well as though
for your union
and this would fulfill one of putin's
unset goals
dividing us
the second must be for energy
independence
indeed our massive dependence on russia
for raw materials and energy is a
primary reason for europe's lack of
determination to deter the russian
regime up until now no surprise when
forty percent of our gas thirty percent
of our coal overall and of our nuclear
fuels don't forget that is provided by
russia sdu is almost devoid of these
resources his whole plan really to
replace this massive dependence from
russia with another equally massive
dependence from anyone else
we think that energy independence is the
key for the eu to become a respected
geopolitical player
and that will never be achieved by
putting gas and nuclear at the heart of
our energy strategy
as the president said
only renewables and energy efficiency
can give us a strategic autonomy we seek
it is not just for the climate that we
must accelerate the energy transition it
is for our security
and for the resilience of our economies
the colleagues
never before has the european union be
challenged in such a direct
and brutal way
i have no doubt
that we collectively
and only collectively have the strength
the resources the determination and
above all the wisdom to meet this
challenge
together together with ukraine because
we belong together thank you thank you
i give the floor
now to marco zanni
on behalf of the id group
president president
president
imagine
thank you
thank you mr zanni i give the floor next
on behalf of the eci group to mr alexo
madam president
the walk the walk created an entirely
new situation
and we have to do everything we can
to win this war because it's our war
the war of all european nations
once putin decided to go ahead with the
invasion
it became clear
he is determined to subdue ukraine
and will not hesitate to resort
to the extreme measures
it was he who once said let me remind
you
that the collapse of the soviet union
had been the greatest
geopolitical tragedy of the century
so there should be no misunderstanding
as to his intentions
he plans to create what was once the
soviet empire
perhaps not with one stroke
but that is definitely his final
objective
moreover
uh he was he has been
more or less open about it all along
the ukrainian army
and the ukrainian people are opposing
the invaders
and they need they desperately need some
military backup arms and other tools of
defense
fortunately after the initial
opposition from some countries
nowadays it is about
20 governments i think that started
helping the ukrainians
and it's very good that some time ago
in the council the member states decided
to create european peace facility
and that these funds can be now used to
help ukraine
and i'm proud to say that it is my
government that was first to
propose as early as thursday morning
to activate european peace facility
so the flow of arms
the flow of
necessary technology
and other means of defense must continue
whatever the effects
of the sanctions
who will win the war will be ultimately
decided on the
battlefield
and and finally i must say this i'm
sorry i must say this because as usual
the eu is with its uh
narcissistic and
self-congratulatory proclivities
likes to escape responsibility
putin made his decision
because he was induced by the weakness
of the west
let us be frank
he did not think much of the western
leaders and it showed he didn't hide it
and in a way he was right having been
for a long time
pampered
by the french and german governments
by some administ american
administrations
also by the european commission that was
both unable
and unwilling
to stymie the north stream projects
to those western leaders and governments
that took upon themselves the job of
dealing with russia
particularly to the german politicians
but not only to them we must say today
ladies and gentlemen you blew it
and your leadership credibility is gone
it's time for a reset and let us start
and let us start
by enabling ukraine to join the european
union
i give the floor next to manoa aubrey on
behalf of the left group
madam lab president madame president
responsibility
is
[Music]
i give the floor next on behalf of the
non-attached members to klinger gal
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
ukraine signed in their blood
the eu membership
i myself must apologize the ukrainians
and all others that i was too weak
to convince my friends in the west in
time
that putin is a major threat
and then the biggest provocation is not
our nato or eu memberships
but not being invited enjoying nato and
the eu but today there are no more
eastern or western europeans
there is only our joint responsibility
for european continent
i want to turn to the russians
you also can stop the war criminal putin
i understand that you yourselves are
imprisoned and poisoned with lie
but join us nonetheless
the ukrainians are dying for euro also
for a free russia
some human being in the kremlin must act
too
to isolate this war criminal with a
nuclear button in his hands
those maps
who went to the occupied crimea
must now go to putin
and stop him
ukrainian blood binds you
we are witnessing the beginning of an
end for putin
when that end will come i cannot tell
you
i only know that we must do all
that is in our power to bring it closer
thank you ukraine slava ukrainian
[Applause]
[Music]
what
[Music]
mr chairman president uh
high commissioner
dear colleagues dear ukrainians
today we are back to 28 in the european
union again
ukraine has emerged
as a great member of the european family
ukraine is bravely
fighting for european values and freedom
for europeans
let us give ukraine its due
providing a candidate status now
and then accepting it in the european
union
every day
that passes makes things worse for
ukraine and we cannot allow it today the
future and the fate of europe is at this
take in ukraine
russia's
treacherous operation
only confirms
the putin's regime's choice to draw new
red lines on the face of europe
by ordering the attack on ukraine the
russian leader putin has become a war
criminal and has brought the belarusian
dictator lukashenko with
they
him
already in the dustbin of history
their actions are already condemned and
soon be to be convicted
let us give ukraine a weapon
with which it can defend itself against
the aggressor it's our duty
and let us provide humanitarian aid to
its people who are suffering from the
crimes of its aggressor
this support must be such that the west
can look ukraine in the eye let us
isolate russia
the full political economic
and cultural blockade
keep russia down
kremlin cronies out
and the russian people close
ukraine's victory is our victory
[Applause]
next
we did not ask
for this confrontation
ukrainians did not ask for this
confrontation
ukrainians didn't spread hate
ukrainians didn't dream of empires
ukrainians did not dictate their
neighbors what policies to follow and
which alliances to join ukrainians did
not occupy did not annex and did not
blackmail
those actions came from moscow
and my heart is bleeding when i say
those words
but ukrainians
all they want
is to live a free life
in a free country
this is not much to ask
but this is a lot to defend
and this is why
it is our european moral imperative to
help to help ukrainians with refuge and
money but yes also with military
equipment
to help them defend their own choice to
help them save their children
their families
their loved ones the loved ones who take
arms and walk to battles
help them
to return
and yes
this is why
we have no other options than to put
a clear alternative in front of
president putin
either you stop this war now
or you will have to bear
the consequences that will be
devastating
we did not ask for this confrontation
you did
[Applause]
kofo
you're the next
[Music]
tag forward
is
[Applause]
be
thank you cher today we are not simply
condemning an unjustifiable aggression
today we stand up united in this house
to face the criminal invasion of an
authoritarian regime against
international law our principles are
values therefore against all of us
putin's cynical bet assumes he would
quickly overthrow the ukrainian
democracy with his divisions on the
ground but also brings other divisions
no less dangerous through propaganda in
fear within our countries among our
peoples our abundant duty is to make
sure that it will fail with our resolute
support to the right resistance in
ukraine and its official recognition as
eu candidates and with the immediate
adoption of new solidarity package based
on common european bonds we must
immediately support also our companies
and families who will suffer the dark
consequences of the dutiful sets of
sanctions aimed at bringing moscow to
the negotiating table this is not the
war of all the russians
this is a crime perpetrated by a tyrant
and its accomplices thousands of
citizens are bravely taken to the
streets to shout their clear no risking
their lives to oppose his imperialistic
revvings they deserve our full support
this existential threat is a crucial
moment in our history and calls for
exceptional efforts if we really want to
protect peace democracy and our common
destiny sometimes it takes courage to
grow up and become who we really are
okay
[Applause]
piccolo
[Music]
ukraine
[Applause]
ukrainian
a
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
thank you president
i salute
heroism
and and
resistance of ukrainian people
uh facing the unprecedented aggression
from
the kremlin putin's
russia russian federation
[Music]
i
really admire
heroism of ukrainian leadership
president zelinski always defines his
place in universal history i admire
heroism of commanders
soldiers and in particular
ordinary people you are invincible
it is our war
as well and in the in resisting
aggression you are the best part of us
the west
we are honored
by your request to become
a member of the european union
we'll do
our utmost
to provide you candidacy status as soon
as
possible and immediately
on
an unprecedented
uh
rules the the membership therefore
because we need you and of course you
need us in this
i speak on on behalf of entire ecr
polish delegation all of them fully
support the resolution as negotiated by
me thank you
thank you very much
our next speaker is mr pineda nano
[Music]
[Music]
it
dear brothers and sisters in ukraine
dear colleagues
first of all i would like to praise
heroism of ukrainian people i would like
to praise heroism of ukrainian soldiers
and the heroic leadership of president
vladimir zelensky
ukrainians are facing and defending
themselves against the war launched by
real new nazi regime in kremlin
putin is a real war criminal ukrainians
are suffering because we in the west
till now were too weak to stop putting
crimes from the very beginning
ukrainians with their blood are fighting
for their right to reunite with europe
they are more europeans than many of us
that is why we need to give some
candidate status immediately and then we
need to design special fast procedure
for ukrainian ukraine to join us there
is an example of such a special
procedure when in 1990 eastern germany
integrated into european union and it
took less than one year so let's
establish a special procedure also for
ukraine's swift reunification with
europe
after you started to deliver
weapons to ukraine when swift and other
banking sanctions were introduced we
need next steps first of all we need to
stop imports of russian oil and gas
immediately each day we are paying to
putin for 100 new t-70 72 tanks twice
more than ukrainians are able to destroy
during one day on the battlefield
second let's create multi-billion free
ukraine fund to support resilience
reconstruction and modernization of
ukrainian economy let's finance it in
the same way as we finance
next-generation new fund we see you
borrowing in the markets thanks jose
borel for a good idea said let's
introduce full-scale swift and other
sanctions also against criminal
lukashenko and his banks and the last
point
stable peace on european continent will
be possible only if deputization of
russia will happen with the help of
ukrainian victories on the battlefields
with our sanctions and with the help of
ordinary russians protesting on the
streets deputization of russia is coming
closer and closer
mr putin you lost this criminal war
international tribunal in haiti is
waiting for you for justice to be served
justice first of all ukrainians rasam
the perimorgan
[Music]
[Applause]
colleagues i am proud at how strong and
united we are today but we have to be
honest we have been painfully slow and
painfully late waking up to the true
nature of putin's russia
i hope that today we finally truly
understand the urgency and the
existential nature of the current
situation
if we do
it is imperative that we support ukraine
in every way possible without holding
anything back
this includes lethal defensive equipment
economic and humanitarian aid help to
refugees and yes also launching in
honest and accession process for ukraine
to join our union
regarding sanctions on russia
for as long as the criminal ideology of
putinism remains in power in russia we
have to go beyond punishing individuals
and take the strategic decision of
systemically weakening russia's economy
and industrial base
this is in our vital security interest
yes sanctions hit ordinarily russians
too and they are not our enemies but
let's admit it it is primarily the
responsibility of the russian people to
make sure that they're mad sar
cannot kill innocent people abroad
we should fully expect and when possible
encourage the russian people to take
that responsibility seriously slovakia
thank you president
um the courageous ukrainian people are
standing up
to an evil act of aggression
europe answers ukraine's call for help
rise up to defend those who are fighting
for freedom and democracy
the eu is showing unity
and we are finding showing that we are
not just a soft power
we are crippling russia's economy
isolating putin's regime
and reinforcing ukraine's defense
but this is just the start
and we have to do more by excluding more
russian operators and banks from swift
by blocking the russian central's bank's
use of western currencies
and we should even consider blocking
russian ships in our harbors
and more also we have to increase our
support for ukraine's economy and
defense
with money
and weapons
my message to the ukrainian people
europe stands with you slava ukrainia
thank you
yannick
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
ukrainian mercy
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
yes
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
european
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
europe
[Music]
[Applause]
a
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yes
um
[Music]
um
thank you
mr yanskaya you are the next one
in alla brutalite with an fortune
[Applause]
onboard this
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
it mr president thank you
the russian military aggression and
invasion against ukraine is is legal it
is unprovoked it is unjustified
this is indeed a crucial and historical
moment the moment of truth as commission
president oslo fonda line pointed out
too many times in the past the
international community has been blind
in front of unfolding tragedies
today we as a european parliament are
sending a strong
and a united message to the kremlin that
we stand with ukraine in full solidarity
as chair of the foreign affairs
committee i would like to thank the
colleagues from the different political
groups who drafted and negotiated this
resolution and i call on colleagues to
vote in favor
i fully underline the very good
arguments we have heard today
i want to add one point
let us also strongly condemn the
involvement of belarus in this
aggression against ukraine
it was during last week's
inter-parliamentary conference on the
cfsp and csdp in paris
that svetlana zikanowska
it very clear that the assault on
ukraine wouldn't have been possible if
dictator lukashenko wouldn't have had
provided russia the land and the
infrastructure the lukashenka regime has
assisted and enabled this russian
aggression for this reason the eu should
apply further appropriate sanctions also
on belarus dear colleagues the world
will hold russia
and belarus accountable for their
actions thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you colleagues
[Music]
dear colleagues
today we feel sadness
anger for sure but also pride
pride in the unity of the european
response to
putin's war crimes
could you imagine just for one second
that we did not have the european union
today
then we would be divided and divided we
cannot have any response to putin
but united as we stand today we have
ukraine's back
mr zelensky
i know you have other things to do
but you know we have your back
we stand with you we stand with your
people in full solid solidarity in fight
for peace freedom and democracy
and it is clear putin will only listen
to clear messages so we need to to use
this clear language
so that therefore i think it's important
that we stop buying
gas from russia
we need to cut up from that gas
it's at a high price but it is doable
and if we do not pay the price today
we will be presented with the price
tomorrow and president zelinski was
right
he said this is the crisis of freedom
and democracy
well the colleagues in europe let's take
this fight
and stand up for our values thank you
very much
mercedes
thank you dear president
dear colleagues we have a world in
europe on a scale and of a type we told
belong to the history books
and let me be clear this is not
the war of russian people
this is the putin's war
putin's regime is the one to blame for
walking the war killing civilians
destroying country's infrastructure
putin has attacked democratic values and
european aspirations
of the people of ukraine
but the brave ukrainians
stood up strong
and they deserve fully fled support
colleagues
it's time to be on the right side
of history
and to grant ukraine
with candidate status
dear ukrainians
we will not you will not let you go
i'm sure that the white will win over
the dark
we are with you the great people of
ukraine suave ukraine
president uh dear colleagues now is the
time for actions and clear words so i
will say four things very clearly we can
only live in safety and security within
the borders of the 27 member states of
the union if we are surrounded by
countries which are safe and stable in
our neighborhood this is why defending
ukraine means defending the european
union we have to provide all support
that we can to ukraine including
financial support and here with the
european parliament have a big role to
play we say very clearly we are ready to
spend eu money to support ukraine and to
rebuild ukraine we are ready to spend
you money for defense we are ready to
spend more for democracy in ukraine and
everywhere else where needed as well
secondly when people in ukraine say they
want to join the european union our
answer is yes you are welcome ukraine
belongs to europe ukraine belongs to the
european union this today we say with
the very large majority of pro-european
members of the european parliament we
know there is still a lot to do until
membership many difficulties to overcome
but what proof do we need more than what
the people of ukraine are doing these
days as a proof that the people of
ukraine can overcome all difficulties in
view of becoming member of the european
union one day we start work on this as
soon as possible thirdly the republic of
moldova a country of less than three
million people a neighboring country of
the european union has welcomed more
than 70 000 refugees on their territory
in the past five days they provided food
they provided shelter they provided
support they acted in european spirit on
the basis of european values because
they are
led by a poor european president and the
pro-european government this is why i
say everything that we offer to ukraine
we have to offer to the republic of
moldova right now in terms of eu
cooperation in terms of perspective for
membership the republic of moldova and
ukraine are equally important for the
security of europe and lasting the
invasion of ukraine and the assault upon
kiev would not have been possible
without belarus this is why all
political measures that we apply upon
russia we should apply in the same
manner upon belarus thank you very much
thank you
so much
[Music]
[Applause]
that's
[Music]
thank you mr president
we are all
ukrainians
significant
this one
next to dan nika for one minute
[Music]
to miss tanya fayon for one minute
thank you very much miss fion i give the
floor next to nils uzzakovs for one
minute
distinguishment and president their
colleagues i will speak latvian today
but being myself and ethnic russian i
would like to try to address russians in
russia and in europe as well
it counts
and conclude this
important debate for this house i invite
on behalf of the commission vice
president sebastian which to take the
floor
madam president uh honorable high
representative
dear colleague commissioner mcginess
honorable members of the european
parliament but first and foremost the
ukrainians shannon ukraine
i have to say that i never seen a debate
in european parliament charged with so
much emotions
solidarity
and a sense of common european belonging
as you know we come from different
countries
from different political families but we
are discussing today an attack against
the most
fundamental european values that we all
share
and therefore
today
we are all ukrainians sigourney mifsi
ukraine
because the people of ukraine are
fighting for our values
they are fighting for our freedom
and they are fighting for everything
we believe in for europe as we know it
for europe as we treasure it
and we will need the same unity as we
felt this afternoon in this house in the
days
weeks and months ahead
it's clear that kremlin has failed
in its goal to crush
ukraine
it failed
to break spirits of brave ukrainians
it failed to divide
or scare europe
on the contrary
bravery and courage of all ukrainians
and calm and determine leadership of
president zielenski
and his government energize not only
ukraine and ukrainians but the whole
europe
all democracies and i believe every
peace loving human being in the world
mr president zelinski
we have been working together to reform
ukraine we have been working together on
energy security
on energy
independence
and we will be
working together
to build strong democratic
ukraine
mr president
you ask us
to do proof
that we are with you
and i would like to respond to you
vr
we will make sure that the sanctions are
vigorously applied and not only on
russia but also on billers
we will do our utmost to supply you with
everything you need
and we will be with you to rebuild your
beautiful country after your victory
nobody in europe can doubt today
that the people that stand
up so bravely for our european values
belongs in our european family
and therefore i want to reassure you
that as we welcome your women and
children in poland slovakia hungary
romania and other european countries
that in the same warm receptive way we
will open our arms to ukraine in our
common house of peace democracy
and prosperity called
europe
ukraine
thank you very much vice president
sefjovic and now on behalf of the
council i invite high representative
borrel to take the floor
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
basicos
a
a
[Music]
unprecedented
unprecedented financial measures
will
go on the direction of a potential
default
which will have consequences for the
whole financial system for the global
financial system so
don't don't don't municipal rate the
importance of what we have decided to do
and what will follow
i want to stress that
and now we have to work diplomatically
all over the world
reaching out
all countries
in order to build
a state of the mind in order to
aggressive being condemned
and on that
i can assure you me as her
representative all my colleagues members
of the foreign affairs council
all our delegations all our embassies
will be strongly working in order to get
a result
on the vote the general assembly
this is the most important thing that we
have to do right now
because i repeat this is an issue
which belongs to the foreign security
policy which is intergovernmental and
it's the member states you have to take
the lead on this
response and
diplomatic sphere
the second thing that has been
discussing today and is maybe
more important that
many of us could believe
is the dependency from the gas
president has been saying all the time
we have to reduce this dependency
but i've been listening for the last 20
years that we have to decrease this
dependency
and these dependencies has been
increasing during the last 20 years
so from now on
let's put
we have work in accordance with our
saying
because
we pay 700 million dollars
for the world
for gas and oil and gold imports from
russia
and every year we import 200 billions of
matter meter could be met sorry cubic
meters of gas
we have to increase renewables president
said hydro new hydrogen
but keep in mind
that the amount of power in a country
like italy a year in renewables
is less that half billion meters
cubic meters
so we have in front of us strong work to
do
and we have to remain committed to it
and we have to explain to our people
what does it mean
this is a good occasion to develop the
best most noble side to the political
activity
which is pedagogy
that's the moment to do pedagogy
and i understand the enthusiam and the
approach of a
parliamentarian chamber in a moment like
this i've been parliamentarian as you
many years even president of this house
and i know that this is the moment to
show enthusiasm support
but then we have to go to acts
and next time when you discuss again the
budget of the european union
remember that we need resources for
do
what today we are doing with an
intergovernmental fund
that this parliament has never proved
because it's not
in the
in your competencies
put more
defense and security
on your mindset
stop discussing theology
about
strategic autonomy
call it
the way you want
but we have to be more responsible
we have to take our responsibility more
in our hands
we have to be strategically responsible
and this has nothing to do
against weakening
the transatlantic alliances which by the
way
have been proven to be stronger than
ever
and our united
with the transatlantic partners has been
100
nothing against weakening nato because
we develop
our capacities
we have to become a hard power
i know that the words
may afraid someone
but her power i insist is not just
talking about military
her power is having a power to coerce
the power to influence the decisions of
the others and what we are doing on
these measures
is a lot of our power
be prepared for the answer
be prepared for the consequences
don't put all your strength in your
mouth
don't
say nice things
only
from now on we have to be prepared to
resist
we have to be prepared to act in the
long term
with a clear understanding of which are
our challenges and our capacities
this is the moment for the european
union to discuss about what do we want
to be
what we are
which are the limits
of what we can do
and what do we want to do in the future
and you don't know in order to face the
challenge of the future
there is a lot of things that we have to
review
a lot of things about our procedures our
methods
putting more attention on our capacity
to act
that in the time that we spend on
internal discussions
what's happening today in ukraine
remember me budapest
in 56
i was nine years old
but i remember listening to the radio
how the russian charts
were entering a budapest
but remember me
88
the prague spring
it was an officer in spanish army then
and my unit was put into alert i don't
know why
but it was completely useless
on both cases we did nothing because we
couldn't know anything
but from now on we have to face
a confrontation between us
democracies people who believe on
freedom
a multi-party system where citizens
choose their governments
when we live in a free market
economy trying to put together
economic efficiency and social cohesion
with the autocratic regimes
which are supporting themselves
with a click of people who take
advantage of the system
while the great majority of the people
don't improve their living conditions
all the war treasury that putin is
taking from our gas payments
doesn't go to increase the well-being of
the russian people
the ghost to make more powerful
machines
thank you very much hi representative uh
that concludes the debate the vote is
already open and will be open until
quarter past
four and i now invite all the colleagues
there as many people
in the esplanade waiting for us to
address them looking forward to that
thank you very much
stop
[Music]
stop putting stop walk
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
is
you are
[Music]
[Music]
you are
[Music]
name is europe is
europe
is europe ukraine is europe
[Music]
your brain is european
[Music]
he was stopped
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
stop
stop stop this down
thank you
thank you to all of you who are here
thank you to all the ukrainians who have
joined us today
thank you for being here
i would like to first start
by saying that europe
is with you today
we will be with you tomorrow and we will
not leave your side
we are here in the european parliament
in the house of democracy
and in this house we will work to find a
space for you to send a message that is
so much needed to the world
we hear
your european aspirations loudly
and clearly
and when you look to this house you will
find a friend
and an ally throughout the whole process
because we must face the future
together i give you our commitment for
that
and we know that the courage
and the bravery of the people
of ukraine
this will be a long
and prosperous future
you have inspired
the world
your strength of purpose your defiance
your values
have lit up a spark
across the globe
today
everyone knows what it means to be
ukrainian
and that is thanks to you
and you will find europe
we will help
with weapons with aid with logistics
with massive sanctions and we will do
whatever it takes to hold aggressors to
account
because the age of dictators
and autocrats is over
president putin alexander lukashenko all
the oligarchs who bankroll them will be
held accountable for waging war in
peaceful europe
so long live ukraine long live europe
slovakia